julia walk us through an example of
saying the case of malaria or bed nets
in which you make a distinction I
believe between impact and outcomes and
and how you would convince an investor
this may be a good place to invest well
the whole discussion about impact and
outcomes stems from the notion that you
need to measure impact to know whether
you're reaching the objectives if you
are an impact object impact investor by
definition you aspire to achieve both
financial returns and social impact
understanding whether you achieved your
financial return is easy you look at how
much money you've invested how much
money you received either through
dividends or by returning the capital
it's easy how do you know whether you're
reaching your impact goals that's where
the measurement of impact comes into
play and typically what people would
measure because it's easier is the
outcomes for example to cure malaria a
commercially minded social enterprise
will sell bed nets they would measure
the success of their impact objectives
by measuring the number of beds that
they have sold but in reality doesn't
necessarily mean that they are curing
malaria which is what the end goal is
because maybe those bed nets are not
used maybe people buy them and go
fishing with them so there's not
necessarily dialing direct link between
the outcome basically what are you doing
and the change that you are trying to
affect with this investment